小伙伴们,大家好
我是本次直播的讲师
Traddle Ascent Town的Committer,梁颖冲
你们也可以叫我Ricky
很高兴和大家在Cent训练营
马力全开特辑的直播间中和大家见面
2026Cent训练营
我们设置了全新的四大主题课程
分别是我们的开源基础系列
马力全开特辑
开发者说
以及我们的企业对话专场
同时我们也设置了更多好玩的互动
让各位小伙伴们参与
给大家介绍一下本季全新的训练营玩法
大家可以先截图保存
玩法一
看直播的同时
大家可以扫码到社区的活动页
大家可以一边看一边答题
全部回答正确的前五名小伙伴
可以领取到我们的奖品
玩法二
课后作业
直播课程结束后
我们的一属页也会更新另外的题目
如果全部回答正确的前五名小伙伴
也可以领取到我们的定制茅台一份
玩法三
就是我们的学习笔记
以及我们的直播打卡
我们可以按要求
在我们的生疼论坛上发布我们的学习心得
并提交我们的一属
我们就有机会获得那个社区定制的一份礼物
好
那么我们就回答正题
本次课程的主题就是我们的Trydown Ascent代码架构
以及功能扩展全解析
目前Trydown Ascent仓就是我们的Trydown Ascent代码架构
目前Trydown Ascent仓已经签仓了
以前我们Trydown Ascent是在Gipcode上开发的
为了更加融入我们的Trydown生态
我们把Trydown Ascent仓签到我们的Gipcode上
Trydown是近几年来受到开发者青睐的一个
Python语法的一个编程语言
开发者仅需要关注我们的Tal、Block
他们的切分方法
以及基于我们的Tal、Block
他们来进行我们的逻辑运算
编译器会自动将我们的Trydown代码
在编译的过程里面
结合我们底层硬件的特点
自动完成各类的优化
而在整个编译过程里面
Trydown Ascent就是我们面对生态平台构建的一个Trydown编译框架
旨在让我们的Trydown代码能够在生态硬件上高效运行
那么今天我会分三个部分来跟大家讲解
第一个部分就是我们Trydown Ascent的一个功能概述
第二部分就是Trydown Ascent的一个重点Path介绍
第三部分就是我们的功能拓展
大家可以看到
在实际层上我们有Kernel以及Wrapper
用户在透过Trydown进行开发的过程里面
可以写自己的Kernel以及Wrapper
其后在编译的流程里面
用户可以透过调用我们的Trydown Ascent
Trydown Ascent主要设置于两个组件
第一个部分都是我们的Trydown Ascent Backhead
第二个部分就是我们的Trydown Adapter
在Trydown Ascent Backhead里面
我们有我们的自动寻忧
透过Auto Tuning
Trydown Ascent可以找到一个更好的配置
确保我们的算子能够高效地运作
第二点就是它有个JITS编译
JITS的全身就是Just-in-Time
透过Just-in-Time Compilation
我们可以把算子编译成.o
那么后续
当我们想要跑这算子的时候
我们如果它们的配置是一样的
而算子的原码是一样的话
我们可以把缓存里面
已经编译好的Kernel.o
重新把它调用起来
透过JITS的编译
我们这边也可以减少我们后续
算子编译的时间
第三点就是我们的均匀时调用
Trydown Ascent它可以调用到
根据用户算子所生成出来的Kernel.o
以及一些Runtime的ShareObject
来达到我们的Kernel Launch
透过Trydown Ascent Backend
我们可以生成出我们的TTIR
TTIR就是我们的Trydown Intermediate Representation
透过把我们的TTIR下发到我们的TTAdapter
TTAdapter是一个编辑组件
它主要设计两个部分
第一点就是我看IR Lowering
透过把Trydown语义的一些操作
把它Lower把它转换成我们MRR社区常用的一些操作
TTAdapter就可以把一些Trydown特有的东西
转换成CMPIR
能阅读能处理的一些IR
除此之外
Trydown Adapter也会进行一些优化
其中一个就是我们的仿权优化
这个后续我会详细把它描述
TTAdapter把TTIR转换成我们TTAdapter IR
后续这个TTAdapter IR会下发到我们的SMPIR
SMPIR设计两个主线
第一个就是我们的HFusion
Hyperfusion
它会进行一些硬件无关的优化
后续我们会进入我们到我们的TTIVM
Hyperfusion会按照我们的算子特性
来决定我们的V核跟C核上
应该要运行什么代码
也会按照我们的硬件特性
来续进行我们内存分配
后续我们的SMPIR
会把算子转换成我们的LVM IR
再经过我们的P生编译器
把代码避译成我们的Kernel
如此
ASMPIR就能顺利把我们的TTAdapter
把它转换成一个二进制的Kernel
到最后
在我们Tri-Dot Ascent里面
它就会调用一个运行时
给一个Driver
来把我们的Kernel.O
以及Runtime.SO
把它跑起来完成我们的Kernel's Launch
这边就是相关的功能概述
那么我们要不从一开始
来看看怎么生成我们的TTIR
大家可以看到我们这里有个Tri-Term Python Language
在这个Language里面
我们只是写了一个Add Kernel
在Add Kernel里面
我们这边首先拿了一个Program ID
PID
Program ID是根据用户输入的切分来决定的
所以如果用户选择了切分为4的话
实际上我们会有4个这样的Kernel
每一个Kernel的ID
就是代表你在调用着第几个Kernel
后续
PID会按照着用户这边期望的切分逻辑
把Block Size传进去
变成了我们仿城的一个起点
我们的Block Start
透过把Block Start
照上我们的Tri-Arrange
从0到Block Size
我们就可以拿到一个矩阵
拿到一个Factor
这个Factor就是我们期望的Pointer Offset
Step 2
可以看到我们把Offset
做了一个小于Number of Elements的操作
确保我们后续的仿权不会越界
第三点
我们这边要去Load我们相关的Data
所以大家可以看到有个X Pointer
加上我们的Offset
之后它的Mask就是Step 2算出来的Mask
如此我们可以得到我们的X跟Y
后续我们希望在这个Kernel里面做加法
所以看到这里就像Python Syntax那样
Output等于我们的X加Y
那最后把我们的Output Pointer
扎向我们对应的Offset
之后就把我们的数据以及Mask
把它回传进去我们的Output Pointer上
左边是我们目前的一个Tridon Python Language
而透过我们Tridon Ascent的第一部分
我们可以把这个原码转换成TTIR
TTIR是一个基于MLIR
它所构建出来的一个中间表达式
大家可以看到这里TTIR有个TT.GetProgramID
这里的TT.代表着它的方言是来源于Triton的
而这里原码跟右边的Percentage 0是E对应的
而后边也可以看到这边几个例子
TT.load
Percentage bar这些我会在host里面解释上语义
大家可以看到这里的IR操作
如果用户定义了block size所为的长量是256
那么在IR的操作里面
这里会有个arif.const
这边的数值就和我们的圆满数值是一对应的
后续在Pathom代码里面
会看到这里有TL的ProgramID
这个其实也会变成我们的TritonLanguage的MIR
可以从我TT.getProgramID
后续我们把这个ProgramID成为block size
所以你看到这里有个arif.multiplication
这里是i,是代表这是integer
后续也可以看到这里mask
offset所为N of n elements
所以这边也做了一个比较
是个less than的一个比较
后续也可以看到这边的圆满是一对应的
例如这里的TL.arrange
它最后会变成我们的Triton方言的Mixed Arrange
这里加法就变成一个add pointer
为什么这里的add pointer是要用上我们的Triton方言的呢
原因是在于
X pointer
这个是一个Triton的一个指针
offset是一个vector
所以它们两个加法不能直接附用我们的arif的add
要使用上我们的tt.add pointer
后续看到这%8
我们把它加了之后
我们就可以把这个%8
发到我们的tt.load
进行加载
第一个入餐
就是我们要加载的地址
%6
第二个入餐
就是我们这里的mask
第三个入餐
custom
问mask之后
我们这边是需要为被演掉的代码
为被演掉的地址
来去给到一个预设值
所以
如果用户在low的时候
不加算预设值的话
这个数值会是0
代表
被演掉的数据
来进行加载
会是0
最后经过一连串的预算
我们回到我们的tt.store
可以看到这里也是一样的
第一个入餐就是我们的地址
第二个入餐是数据
第三个入餐就是我们要处理的研码
后续当我们生成了ttir之后
我们需要把它去lower
变成我们的ttadapter
大家可以看到这个ttadapter.ir
这里是并没有我们的tt.dots的
并没有带上我们的triton语言
因为我们需要把我们的triton语言相关的方言
把它变成一个社区上游可以支撑的一个方言
所以大家可以看到
这里是个manref.subview
这里代表着的语言呢
就是我们本来的tt.load
同样的
我的tt.store
就变成我们的bufferization
the materialized in destination
tttadapter.ir的特点就在于
它其实是多种方言的一个集合
当中包括
但不限于
我们的linl
我们的linearalgebra
manref
erif
等等的dialects
ttadapter.ir
其实就是我们assetmpl.ir的一个入口
因为assetmpl.ir
它是可以支持多种语言的
所以tt.adapter要把语言特定的一些操作
把它lower成一个比较社区上有可支撑的一个ir
这样才可以进到我们的assetmpl.ir
进行进一步的编译优化
以及进入我们的lowering
来生成我们的二进制
所以tt.ir
往tt.adapter转换的过程
本质上就是try.dialects
往上述方言的一个转换的一个过程
所以大家可以看到这个图
用户写了trilanguage之后
language之后
language会被compile成我们的trilangir
之后再根据我们不同类型的一个backhand
不同类型的后端
假设别人的后端是用gpu的话
trilangir
就会变成我们trilanggpu.ir
再按照不同的平台
不同的backhand
而去生成它们能运行的二进制
而我们升腾的后端
就会跑上我们的trilangascent这个路
之后生成出我们的linlmir
后续这些mir也会经过我们的ascentpyr
我们的必胜编译器
最后变成我们的升腾二进制
中间过程会有大量的一个编译化
今天我也会特别重视再去描述
我们trilangir到linlmir的一个过程
以及相关的优化
当我们生成了二进制之后
我们需要launch那个kernel
这个kernel的发射是指我们在trilangascent里面
因为本来这些操作是由cpu去指指令的
但是我们希望用上我们npu
来去跑到我的算子
所以在这个过程里面
cpu会往npu发射一个指令
之后把相关的讯息发进去
所以第一次launch一个kernel的时候
会发生以下的步骤
第一步
这是进行我们python的前端编译
trilang会将我们的pythonkernel
编译成我们的ttir
这个过程里面
我们会展开一些循环
也会处理一些长量
后续我们这边也会进行一些优化
以及一些代码生成
最后这个ttir
经过我们的trilangascent
经过我们的ascentpuir
经过我们的businessir
最后变成lvm
最后生成出能在目前的npu上
能跑的汇变代码
由于trilangascent
it's just in time compilation
所以生成出来的一个二进制
会变缓程
放在这个trilangcache里面
下次如果再进行调用
使用着一样的参数
一样的block size
一样的圆码
那么当我们启动kernel的时候
我们就只需要直接加载完成
不需要重新去编译
最后就是启动
当我们有了二进制之后
python运行时
会通过我们的npu driver API
将编译好的kernel代码
参数
例如我们的指针
标量
以及相关的配置
我们的grid size
把它传到npu的命令对列中
npu驱动会随后调度我们的执行
那么
AssembleIR仓的功能概述
就已经说到这里了
我们一起来看看
Tradal Ascent它重点有哪些paths
,这边是最新的Tradal Ascent代码架
这边是最新的Tradal Ascent代码架构
Tradal Ascent它里面有个ttaadapter
它负责把我们的ttair
转换成我们的ttaadapterir
里面包括着我们的autoblockify
descript mask access conversion
dynamic cv pipeline
tradal affinity opt
tradal to annotation
tradal to graph
tradal to execution
tradal to hivm
tradal to linl
tradal to lvm
tradal to structure
以及tradal to unstructure
我这边抽取了部分重点的paths
来给大家去分享一下
其中比较常见的就是tradal to linl
tradal to execution
tradal to highvm
以及我们的tradal to lvm
tradal to linl做的事情就是
把我们tridon方言的op
转换成linl
manref
tanser
等等的mlir
上区
社区上游的方言
我们透过复用社区的语义定义
可以提升与社区的兼容性
举个例子
这里的tt-doc broadcast
实际上
它是跟我们的linl broadcast
语义是一样的
透过转换我们的tradal broadcast
变成我们的linl broadcast
我们smpir
也只需要关注我们的line-out broadcast
我们不需要关注我们的语言上游
是用着哪一种语言
同样的道理
tridon reshape
看着只是变成另一种方言的reshape
但是这边也是帮我们的smpir
来进行语言程的接偶
让tridon语言相关的一个操作
变成社区上游
共同的操作
这个也让我们的smpir
可以支撑到多种的语言
后续大家可以看到
我们这里有个make range
从0到4096
也就代表这个是一个factor
从0到我们的4095
后续
我们把我的pointer 把我的argument word 就是我们的一个出餐pointer
把它splats了 之后再进行add pointer 再把它存起来
把这个percentage6存到我们的percentage9内
而这里的一连串的一个行动呢
我们这边其实就已经把它简化成我们的manref.reinterpreted cast
大家可以看到 本来的argument1还是这里的入餐
但是 我们在add pointer的过程里面
我们其实是把0到4095加在这个pointer里面
所以呢 这里其实整个pointer就等于我们要访问
这个argument1第0格 argument1第1格 第2格一直到我们的第4095格
所以你可以看到这里定义的size是4096
这里是把一个manref位置的dynamic shape
把它变成一个static shape 变成4096的size
同时大家看到这里的make range percentage7后面没有再进行任何的惩罚
所以它是0123这样去读取
所以它的strike就是1
后续这个values20就是我们组装好的pointer
我们只需要把这个values之旧
我们reshape出来的结果
把它写到我们的values20
那么就完成了我们的triton to lean out的一个lowering
当然triton to lean out还有它的局限性
举个例子
如果lean out等等的上游方言
它们都没有这个能力去承载我们的triton无关的一些操作
那么我们就是要用上我们的triton to execution
triton to hfm
以及triton to lvm
举个例子
这里的tt.histogram
其实在上游方言里面没有相关的承载能力的
所以为什么这里是需要直接生成出我们的hfm.histogram
再往下
可以看到我triton to hfm
因为有些特有些硬件墙相关的op
它们无论是在lean out还是在hfm等等的方言里面
都没有相关的语意的
所以triton to hfm pass
会把相关的triton方言直接下降成我们的hfm方言
举个例子
例如我们的triton ins to pointer
它是把一个Integer cast成一个Pointer指振地址
而透过triton to hfm
我们可以直接把它变成hfm方言里面的
PointerCast
把这个Falue时期
这一个露出来的一个Percentage 露出来的一个结果
把它去进行一个运扇
最后就是triton to hfm
为了增加我们整个语言的应用性
有部分的hfm接口
其实是在我们语言层上对开发者暴露的
而triton to hfm pass
就是把这些暴露在triton上的op
直接转换成hfm的op
取个例子
我们的hfm inline assembly
我们支撑在triton里面使用上它
所以在ttir里面会看到tt.elementwise inline assembly
我们把相关的参数直接
lower成我们的hfm方言的一个操作
这个就是我们triton to hfm的一个功能
刚刚给大家介绍的都是一些转换的pass
但triton ascent尤其是triton adapter
它涉及的不光是我们的转换
也涉及到我们的优化
大家可以看到在这个优化里面
我们分成我抽出了其中四个比较有用的
比较常用的一个特性给大家讲解一下
第一个就是autoblockify
这个pass它能够把多个逻辑盒合并成一个逻辑盒
来减少我们的开销
第二个是triton destructure
以前这个叫做triton linearizer
这个pass就是透过分析我们的low store
来把一些非线性的指令
变成一些升等DM指令可使用的一些OP
第三个就是我们discrete mask conversion
这个discrete mask asset conversion
就是透过分析我们的mask
买些感知
这个mask是离散的还是连续的
最后再进行相关的conversion
最后一个就是triton to unstructure
这个pass做的事情就是把一些离散纺尘
来去把它进行处理
首先我们可以先讲我们的autoblockify
为了提升我们的升等情和性
autoblockify会按照我们指定的blockify size
来去修改我们的企业分大小
把多个逻辑盒合并成一个blockify后的一个逻辑盒进行运散
举个例子你可以看到这里有四个逻辑盒
我们在autoblockify v2后可以把四个逻辑盒把它合并成成一个
这个autoblockify v2也是我们tryon to unstructure里面实现的
这个也会是今天会特别去关注的一个特性
后续进入到我们的sample.ir之后
它会执行autoblockify v2
这个v1后续会更加的进行我们相关的blockify
来去减少我们启用我们的kernel的开销
具体的算法我这边可以举个例子
假设我们的grid分别是5,3,2,x为5,y为3,z为2
那么它总共的逻辑盒数量就是5乘3乘2等于30
假设用户要把autoblockify v2的size设定为7
那么这就代表每7个逻辑盒要并在一起
所以blockify后的第0个逻辑盒
它要执行的就是本来index0到6的逻辑盒运算
同样的道理
blockify后的逻辑盒1
它就会执行原kernel的7,8,9,10,11,12,13
如此类推
直到去到我们的blockify后的第4个逻辑盒
由于我们只有5乘3乘2
我们只有30个逻辑盒
所以第4个逻辑盒它只会执行我们的index28跟index29的逻辑盒运算
后续的后续就不会参与运算了
所以可以看到本来我们要执行30个逻辑盒
透过autoblockify
我们把逻辑盒的数量直接除以7
剩下5个
这样的话我们每次启用我们的好代码的时候
我们就可以减少我们的开销
但是在我们改了他们的切分逻辑之后
有些运算其实我们都是要修改的
举个例子
如果我们本来的代码里面我们需要感知到我们的program id
假设本来用的id就是x
那么我们新的代码是不是那个id要改一下呢
因为这里y跟zag乘一起只有6个
所以从00到05里面
他们的xid都是0
从06到我们11
他们的xid都是1
就是因为这样的原因
我们需要去重新去算我们的new pidx
pidy以及pidzag
可以看到我们要把autoblockify id
就是这个个0,0,1,0,2,0,3,0,4,0,5,0,6
把它除以我们的y跟x
这里就会得出这里除以6
再做一个following
所以这里的数字就会是
0,0,0,0,0,0,0,1
5个0,1个1
后续再去做个mod x
因为他们都是0跟1
所以就mod x之后
还是这里5个0,1个1
所以在blockify后的第0个逻辑盒
它前面这5个是处于我们的pidx0的
这里就是pidx1
同样的道理
这里的blockify1
blockify第一个逻辑盒
它的index1逻辑盒
前面这里就是xid为1
这两个就是xid为2
如此类推
我们就可以正确的把我们的kernel
在转化的过程里面
正确的把我们的program id 算起来了
同样的道理
pidy,pidzag也是一样的算法
我们把这个blockify id除以zag
那么再去mod y
那么就会得出00跟01
它的yid就是0
02跟03 yid是1
04跟05 yid是2
因为我们的y只有3
所以到06跟07之后
这里的yid也会变成0
如此类推
这个就是autoblockify的特点
因为我们在用户写代码的过程里面
我们希望可以提供一个高度抽象的一个接口
所以用户不是要感知我们
硬件上实际上有多少个核
多过autoblockify
我们可以把多个逻辑核
按照着我们硬件的特点
硬件上实际上有多少个核
多过autoblockify
我们可以把多个逻辑核
按照着我们硬件的特点
来去进行对应
来避免我们过度的开销
说完了我们的autoblockify
下一个pass就是我们tridon to structure
tridon to structure
本来又叫做我们的tridon linearization
它就是透过分析
以及转换我们的仿尘表达
来去消除一些非线性的部分
当中包括解析复杂的一些表达式
流入我们的除法
取余
惩罚
加法等等
透过这些讯息
我们可以把offset
size跟stripe
来去得出
来把本来我们认为是离散仿尘的东西
结构化起来
变成一个可以透过我们深藤DMA指令
访问的一个操作
可以看到
穿通语言本来它是服务GPU的
所以它是有一个SIM体的特点
有一个Single Instruction Multiple Thread的一个特点
这个特点呢
它可以进行离散仿尘
把多个原地址进行MultiStract的仿尘
但是
因为在A2E3上
我们只有SIMD
只有Single Instruction Multiple Data
所以呢
这里的离散仿尘
就会打致到
我们只能用我们标亮来去仿尘
性能会十分的差
而透过我们的Tri-Ton Structure
我们
可以把这些东西
组装成一个Tensor
我们透过把它组装成一个正确的二维Tensor
正确的运算它的Size
运算它的Stripe
把它变成一个Tensor
变成一个MainRef
这样的话
我们就变成深藤清河了
所以这个就是我们Tri-Ton to Structure
把一些不能够去
我们会进行一个分析
来去把数据把它组装起来
把它变成一个SIMD
的一个清河的指令
除此之外
我们还有我们的Descript Mask
Acess Conversion
这个Path
就是透过分析我们LowStore里面的Mask
来去识别出我们Mask
这个是一个离散的Mask
还是一个规整的Mask
或者离散式的Mask
之后我们就会加上对应的指令
来进行处理
规整的Mask
会有本来的逻辑来去处理
这个Path
主要就是进行相关的分析
以及进行相关的离散
研码的一个优化
你的支撑
我们先来定义一下
什么叫做规整的研码
什么叫做离散的研码
规整的研码
它只会遮掩着DMA操作的前跟后
它不会在中间里面挡着的
去确保我们DMA的元素是延续的
所以
我们也不是要经过其加上任何的操作
也可以直接访问
举个例子
可以看到这里Mask
它是TL Arrange
从0到8
也就是0到7
我们0123567
我们这边检查Mask是要大于4的
所以0
都是不要漏出来的
而我们的4567
就是要加载出来的
而这种场景下
我们实际上
只需要把它变成一个Sulfill
就可以支撑起来了
Sulfill的Obset
就填这个4
它的Size也是填4
那么
就已经能够做到相关的支撑了
或者
另一种
我们除了刚刚的要大于4
我们也加个限制
要小于等于6
这样就只剩下456了
但是456它本质上还是连续的
所以呢
这里也是一个Sulfill
Obset
跟上面一样
只是它的Size
变成只有3
规整的沿码其实是挺好处理的
因为我们可以直接生成一个Sulfill的操作
但是如果这是一个离散的沿码呢
离散的沿码
大家可以看到这个例子
我们还是弄了一个Mask
从0到8
我们这里取%2
数值就会变成010101
我们再让它检查是不是等于1
自然就是False
不去加载
True
要去加载
False true
这种场景下
我们怎么去让我们访问到
怎么可以让我们的DMA指令
可以高效去访问它呢
我们做的事情就是
透过Select
Select操作的入餐就是我们的Mask
如果我们在做加载做Load的时候
我的Mask是False的话
我们会用Other来组成一个矩阵
如果Load的时候没有设定Other
R的就是0
所以Select的时候
就从我们要输出的矩阵里面
以及我们的R的矩阵里面
去进行一个Selection
那么我们就能达到我们带有离散叠码的一个访问了
又是Store呢
Store的话
我们如果是True的话
就要把原数据矩阵把它存进去
就要把输入矩阵存进去
如果是False的话
我希望东西不要变
不要变的话
我就把原数据交载出来
再做Selection
这样就是我们的原数据了
以及我们的输入之间做Selection了
透过这种做法
我们就能够顺利的完成我们的离散研码的一个Load
跟Store
它们增加的开销
就是多插入我们的Select子里
后续我会讲到我们的离散仿权
以及我们离散研码的仿权区别
大家可以看到
离散研码最强调的是什么呢
它强调的是Mask
一定要为连续的
这种跳着的
是不允许的
但是如果我们是离散仿权呢
大家可以看到这里
右下角这里
离散仿权
我们这里想要加载第0格
第2
第4
第6格的数据
这里在我们定义上
它是一个连续的仿权来的
因为这里
我们的定义就是看它的Strike
是不是一样
我们在写Tensor的时候
我们是可以决定它的Strike是怎样的
所以
大家可以看到
Mask的话
它是在意它的连续性
而如果是Offset的话
它在意的
就是这里的Strike
是不是固定的
所以
Offset
从0到3
乘2
就是0
这个在我们定义上
也是连续仿权
而离散仿权
而离散仿权呢
举个例子
这里从0到3
我们做个Element-wise的乘法
0到3
就变成0
0到1
它的Strike
是1
1到4
Strike是3
我们的4到9
Strike是5
显然意见
这里的Strike
它是不固定的
所以
这个就是我们的离散仿权
而在我们的Tried on to Unstructured Path
它除了涉及我们的轴分析
看着这里
来去感知
这个是一个离散仿权
还是连续仿权
这边也会进行相关的改写
而在我们的Tried on to Unstructured Path
它除了涉及我们的轴分析
看着这里
来去感知
这个是一个离散仿权
还是连续仿权
这边也会进行相关的改写
轴分析
我后续会在下一页来去详细解析
可以看看我们这里怎么改写
假设我们有以下的DMA操作
我们要做一个项目
这个TT load
它的tensor大小是64*128
假设我们这个手轴64
它的stripe是不固定的
而尾轴的stripe是固定的话
那么我们要怎么去处理这个
这个前面是离散的
右面是右右边是连续的纺承呢
由于我们NPO硬件
它是不支撑任何的离散纺承的
我们是需要把我们的手轴进行打散
所以你大家可以看到
这里的64
我们会变成我们的control flow
透过我们的force循环
从我们的c0到我们的c64
每次增加1
把这个
这个iteration argument
传入到我们的extract size里面
这样的话我们手轴就可以
变成我们的离散纺承
一个一个来去访问了
而由于我们的尾轴它是128
这个是一个固定的stripe
所以呢
extract size也可以把这个128直接放在这里
这样就是我们怎么去进行离散纺承的改写了
但是问题是在于
我们知道要这样改写
但是我们要怎么分析呢
这边右边看着很简单
大家看一看就知道他们的stripe是不固定的
这边看着他的stripe是固定的
这个当然很好去理解
而实际上我们在分析的过程里面要考虑的事情
十分之多可以看一下我们后期的描述
我们tripe to unstructured parts
会对每根轴
来具体分析
而轴的类型具体可以其实分为以下四种
第一种就是标亮轴
标亮轴它的size就是1
而零部复轴
就是举个例子
我们把一个标亮
把它splat着
把它broadcast着
这样的话举例我把一个标亮为1的
数字把它broadcast
成128的大小
数据全都是1
这样的话
以这个东西作为offset的话
我每次point都是load
或者store我的index1
这样的话
它的stripe就是0
后续就是我们的规整轴
规整轴的定义就是
我们的stripe
要是固定的
就好像刚刚的例子
我把0到3
的一个矩阵
把它乘以2
它的stripe是2
所以这里还是一个规整的
离散绑成离散轴
就正如我刚所描述的
他们stripe是不固定的
这样的话就是跟离散轴
我们做arrange的时候
只需要输入
我们开始的index1
跟结束的index1
或者有时候也不是要输入开始的index1
我们就可以得出一个规整的一个数字
可能从0到100
这里就stripe是1
所以这个是一个规整轴
后续
到了我的加法跟减法操作
假设是两个标量加起来
那么它的size
当然也是1
所以呢
这里
标量跟标量之间做了任何加减
我把offset3
再加个5
offset只是变成8
但是我只是访问着pointer的第8个index
所以这里
也是一个标量的一个轴
如果是标量跟0不复的一个轴来去做一个加或减呢
那他们本质上还是一个0不复的轴
以刚刚的作为例子
假设有一个0不复的一个全为3的轴
跟一个0不复全为5的轴
这个加法
本质上
我们只是把我们的offset
变成8
同样的道理
如果我们是
标量轴
0不复轴
跟规整轴
和任何的规整轴做个加法的话
它就是一个规整轴
举个例子
如果
如果我们的规整轴是0123
我们往它
去加个4
就变成
本质上他们strike还是1
加上标量
或者加上我们的0不复轴
只是影响它的offset
但是offset不是我们在意的地方
因为决定它是不是规整
是看的strike
不是看的offset
同样的道理
我们的规整轴跟规整轴相加
例如举个例
我们是
加0123
那么本质上
它就是0
它还是一个规整轴
当然这里目前
所有给到的一个描述都是一个比较
simplified的描述
实际上它是有一些特例的
特例也会在代码里面去做个描述
但这里只是为了方便大家理解
也可以看到
如果不是上面的情况
其他的情况呢
只要加上我们的离散轴
它本质上还是跟离散轴
这里是个加法跟减法的一个操作
如果是惩罚跟除法呢
首先呢
惩罚
它是满足那个交换率的
它是满足那个associative rule的
所以
第一个rule
它左右是个互换的
但是division
它不满足那个associative rule
所以左右是不能互换的
在惩罚场景里面
我任何一根轴
只要是成绩漂亮的话
它本质上
就是把他的strike
成大对应的倍数
举个例子
乘以我们全为3的一个零部副轴
这变成
本质上呢
这里
他还是规整的
因为他的strike是3
但是
倘若是其他操作的话
就会变成离散了
以除法为例子
假设他是规整轴跟规整轴
如果是100
跟我们300
他去除我们的
他们的strike是100
他们的strike是1
看着两个都是规整的呀
但是如果当我们做了除法之后
100除以4
200除以5
就是40
最后就是300除以6
就是50
大家可以算一下
其实算出来的结果
他们
两个数字之间
的差距不是一样的
也就代表着他们的strike
不是一样的
所以除法场景
就是这样
能代表着
这个是一个离散轴
而同样的场景
乘法
刚刚已经描述了
乘以0123
就是0
自然
他的strike不是固定的
就是离散
后面也有我们的extract slice
我们无论那根轴
本来是离散的
还是规整的
还是如何的
只要我extract
我extract size的时候size为1
因为标亮轴的定义就是size为1的轴
所以任何轴
做完extract size
with size equal to 1
它就是一个标亮轴
如果是一个非零的不负轴呢
如果是一个
规整轴或者离散轴
首先标亮轴
已经不能做任何这里size等于2或离散的操作了
规整轴或者离散轴
如果我在这里extract size
选了两个元素
两个元素之间
他们的strike就只会有一种答案
如果我们的size
再多一点的话
那么这确实
可能有多种不同的strike
但是由于
我们只拿两个element
所以他的strike肯定是固定的
所以这里也是一个规整轴
而这里零不负的轴
如果我怎么选它
它本质上
还是一个零不负的
最后呢就是任何轴
规整轴
我从它当中随便选三个到四个
因为它的strike是一样的嘛
所以我extract size
extract size也不会选
也会确保
元素的连续性
所以规整轴里面去选
任何
extract size选size
也是规整轴
同样道理
零不负轴也是一样
离散轴也是一样
所以这里就是我们的extract size
又是reduce的操作呢
首先我们reduce都是reduce我们的手轴
这是前面这里的
如果我们的tensor是一个标亮轴跟一个任何轴
任意轴
因为我们标亮
本质上就不需要reduce
所以它就变回它自己
但是如果这里是一个任何轴加上标亮轴呢
我们做reduce操作的时候
就是把这个元素
透过
我们的加法
reduce sum
reduce time
reduce multiplication
来去把我们的任何轴
把它变成标亮轴
所以任何轴
都变成标亮轴
因为本来的标亮轴
它已经是size1了
reduce charge后
它的size还是1
最后
还有一些例子
假设我们是零部负轴跟规整轴呢
假设想一下我们的元素
我们有一个3*3的矩阵
第一行是345
第二行也是345
第三行也是345
从左到右
它就是一个规整轴
它的stripe是1
这里的零部副轴
就是从上老下
就是333
以及555
这种情况下
如果我想要对我们的零部副轴
来去做一个reduce
我把333做一个乘法
变成27
我把444做个乘法
变成64
我把555做个乘法
变成125
我们从上往下
333乘在一起
就剩下一个size
剩下一个27了
44变成64
555变成125
这里的第一根轴
就是标样轴
但是我们第二根轴
从左往右
从345
stripe为1
变成27
他们的stripe
自然就是不一样的了
所以reduce
对手轴做操作的话
如果这边是个跟规整轴的话
这边也会变成跟离散轴
实际上reduce的操作
就这里只是部分例子
实际上还可以描述更多
假设这里
它的tensor size
它不只是2
它可以是3
可以是4
可以更多
或者这里
假设是两个都是零部副轴
我这里讲一下
如果两个都是零部副轴的话
reduce的轴会变成漂亮
没有reduce的轴
就会变成我
还是零部副轴
实际上reduce操作
还要更复杂的
这里也不详细描述了
就描述一些具体的例子
让大家后续了解一下
后续也有我们的splat操作
splat的操作就是把我们的标亮轴
把它splat成我们的零部副轴
所以就是把一个例如标亮
我把offset1
splat成一个128长度的E111
这个就是我们的splat操作
所以这边就是try not to unstructure
怎么去进行我们向外推导
最后就得出我们这个DMA
这个loadstore
哪一根轴是离散的
哪一根轴是连续的
是规整的
后续就能够进行我们的一个打散
进行我们的离散仿存改写了
后面就到我们的try not to ascend
功能拓展
我们try not to ascend
目前拓展了一个功能
叫做custom off
背景是因为
现有的算子组合
可能并不满足我们使用者
需要的计算需求
或者开发者
他们希望自己定义的算子
定义的操作
可以保持私有
或者多个算子的组合
并没办法达到我们最优的性能
而我们的custom off
就是允许
用户在
Ascend MPIR的模板库
的template里面
去写自己的c代码
之后变译成我们的.bc
变译成我们的bytecode
之后呢
就能提供到
与其他扇子
一起变译的一个自由扇子
目前custom off
还在work in progress
还在这个开发中
但是部分能力已经提供了
例如我们的core type
我们能选择要执行
cqp还是vector
有我们的pipe type
能选择要用哪一种pipe
有我们的vf mode
我们可以选择这个是要simd的
还是simt的
我们也有这个symbol
来让用户来决定
这个函数的名称
但是目前很多功能
还在实现当中
目前我们自定义算子的
lowering
这个用户自己实现的
目前还在进行当中
还是实现当中
而相关的linking
例如hfmir
链接到我们用户提供的圆码
或者object files
这个能力
还在支撑当中
或者往我们的pccompile
当中注册特定的链接命令
这个也是我们目前在支撑当中
而且我们这边还有限制
就是pass的交互
我们这边要适配我们自定义的算子变化
例如我们的flatten优化
对齐调整
plan memory
布局内存规划
或者我们的layout transform
例如我们的end to end
这些布局变化
这些呢
目前还在支撑当中
这个就是我们customer
我们可以一起看一下相关的例子
可以看到我们这边有两个mlir的用力
第一个就是building
第二个就是customer
在我们的mplir模板库里面
我们这边会定义了一些模板库
在调用的过程里面呢
我们就会透过这个hfm hir
然后customer
来去调用相关的扇子
留这里的building
get a load
这个是我们这边提供的一个building扇子
这边的int跟out
就是根据我们的需求来提供的
而我们的customer呢
这边是用户可以自己保持为prefix的
用户可以在这里输入相关的一些属性
这边是个mlir
我们会提供一个python友善的一个界面给用户使用的
这里有我们的coretype可以选择是factor
也能选择我们的pipetype
这个是factor的pipe
也能选择我们的vfmode
我们的function应该是要simt的
也能决定它的名称
以及加上我们想要的输入以及输出
这边是mlir层的一个示例
如果进到我们的tri-tong自定义算子里面呢
如果用户想要在tri-tong里面
使能你已经生成好的bip.bc
你的.bycode的话
用户只需要在你的class里面
加上这个addal
al stand for
ascentlanguage
只要加上我们的ascentlanguage.registercustomop
再把你的coretype
pipetype
mode type
把它输入进来
之后再进行我们的initialization
决定你的入餐
加上你期望的条件
构建你想要的symbol
调用上你期望调用的bycode
那么整个在tri-tong车的接口已经定义好了
但光定义好这个classadd它是不足够的
我们后续还得要在我们的tri-tongcode里面真的调用上它
所以这里有个tri-tong customadd
customadd就把我们的output pointer
a pointer b pointer传进来
以及对应的size
我们把我们的index把它组装起来
我们加载去我们的a数据b数据
再组装成我们的buffer
根据我们的size我们的l
后续调用上我们这个al.custom
把这个add调用起来
再把对应的输入按照这里的indexualization
把它传进去
后续这里的add.bycode就能被使用起来了
把这个调用起来之后
反馈的结果就会放到这个race里面
我们的result里面
再把我们的output pointer以及我们的index
组装起来变成我们的物理地址
再把我们的result store进去
所以custom op的特点就在于
用户现在可以自己写自己的模板库
自己决定着底层的函数
应该怎么调用
怎么去选出个最优的一个解法
来去让我们的triton ascent
除了保持一个高度抽象
保持一个usability
保持一个高度可用性
应用性之外
我们这边也为了极致性能
对往下把custom op的一些接口
把它往上支撑起来
确保用户在我们的usability
以及我们的performance之间
可以拿到一个很好的平衡
所以今天我就跟大家介绍了三个方向
第一个就是trinel ascent
它整体是怎么编译的
它的功能概述
第二个也讲述了我们的triton ascent重点pass
第三个也跟大家讲述了
我们这个功能拓展
那么我们一起来看看我们的总结
triton ascent
它是一个面向我们生存平台
构建的一个triton编译框架
我的目的就是让我们triton代码
能够在我们的生存硬件上高效运行
其中主要经过的编译流程有四个
第一个就是我们triton python dsl
会把我们的圆码翻译成我们tritir
第二个就是把我们tritir
转换成我们tritadapterir
tritadapterir就是具有我们上游社区各种的方言
来让我们的ascent mpyr比较容易对接
后续也经过我们的ascent mpyr
以及传统的lpnbc9r compiler进行编译化
来生成出我们的binary kernel
最后就是进行我们的kernel launch
去把我们生成出来的kernel
生成出来.o
来去在硬件上执行
从而实现我们
把数据在生存上
并行计算的一个效果
这个就是我们的一个概述
说到我们的Path
主要就是在TDIR
转换成TDAdapter IR的过程里面
由我们TriTone Ascent仓里面的TriTone Adapter完成的
这里就是我们TriTone Ascent最重要的一个模块
这个Path
这个模块
包括了多个重要的Path
例如刚刚描述的AutoBlockify
把多个逻辑核合并成一个Blockify后的逻辑核
来减少我们的Initualization Cost
还有进行到我们的Discrete Mask Access Conversion
来去把不连续的Mask
把它来去做加上一个Slide
又我们TriTone to Unstructure
来把一些离散的仿尘
离散的仿尘指的就是Stripe不固定的一些仿尘
来去把它支撑起来
这个就是我们主要的Path
此外呢
TriTone Ascent也为我们生存清合提供了我们的Custom Ops接口
这个既满足了我们用户对于我们极致性能的追求
也能保持到我们自定义扇子的私有性
这个也增加了我们TriTone编程里面的我们极致性能的这个追求
这个也增加了我们TriTone编程里面的生存清合
确保我们写出的算子是在生存上有一个很好的性能的
所以这边就是我们TriTone Ascent的一个总结
我们目前TriTone Ascent已经开源了很多的代码了
大家可以扫一下左边跟右边
左边就是我们的TriTone Language
这是我们的TriTone Language
GipHub里面的TriTone Language
TriTone Ascent
可以扫一下
Style一下
也十分推荐大家
往我们这边右边的GipHub
Ascent
Ascent NPRR里面
大家可以扫一下这个stock
我这边给大家一点时间
来扫一下这个这边的stock
后续呢
我们这边也会进行一些生态的供建
有兴趣的话
大家可以扫一下我们这个sig交流群组
我们这边会定期每周往这个sig群组里面
发布相关的文章
以及进行我们的代码总结
我们这边也会有相关的一个sig会议
的一个历程
以及相关的一些会议历程
我们这边也会持续的为大家
去提供我们的训练营
来去让大家更加了解我们的TriTone Ascent
以及Ascent NPRR
这边给一点时间
大家去扫一下我们这边的stock
而我刚刚前面介绍了
我们的玩法1
我们这边在看直播的同时
大家可以扫码到我们的社区活动页
一边看一边答题
我看已经有些小伙伴
已经在我们的活动页
一属页里面底下评论答案了
本次直播互动的三道题答案
分别就是我们的
C
B
A
重复一次就是我们的
C
B
A
评论区前面
答对前五名的小伙伴
我们可以私讯小助理
来领取我们的奖品
如果我们没抽到奖品的小伙伴也不是要灰心
最后作业以及我们的学习笔记也会有机会拿到我们的奖品的
大家可以扫码
报名我们的CAN训练营
更多的挑战
以及丰厚的奖品在等待着大家来领取
大家可以扫描
萤幕上的二维码
聚约我们的下一场直播
每一来得及观看直播的开发者
可以在B站
搜索我们的深藤CAN
来观看我们的回放
以上就是今天马力全开特级直播的全部内容
我们下一期再见
未经许可,不得翻唱或使用